so I want to record 15 milliseconds
15,000 1,500 family yet 15 my mates 15
1015 thousand is 15 seconds okay go on
them
alright how real is this thing on
hello and welcome to computer file that
looks pretty good here I kind of wanted
a bit of advice because I've bought this
Raspberry Pi 4 and it seemed pretty
powerful so I thought why not try and
make a video on it I just want to see if
I can I it could do video editing
right ok so presumably you want me to
put it together ok I bought one of these
too when they came out there they are
incredibly powerful machines for what
they are
we've now got a quad-core CPU and again
it's been upgraded from before the RAM
is now separate we've got 4 gigs of RAM
on here instead of one gig the thing
that interested me most is Gigabit
Ethernet USB 3 which means we've got
pretty decent connectivity off this and
get 5 gigabytes per second I think off
here one gigabit a second off that got
some USB 2 ports for things like
keyboard and so on so it's great well I
mean I think lots of interesting things
you can do this week did some
interesting things the other week with
the Raspberry Pi 3 it's got the
potential we're feeding we can we
definitely know we can feed 30 megabits
per second video to these things and
they can cope so you've got you've got
enough a chance with this so let's let's
get it up and running for you what else
have we got here I see you've been off
the shopping primer only to be fair and
even-handed some of that stuff came from
the pilot as well okay so other pie
shops are available so what are we go go
heat sink these things do get warm so
they're quite good but we also have the
PI fan as well as let's start with that
you start with the fan and put the heat
sink on as well if we need to because it
works better and we've got a camera and
a power supply let's move over to the
other desk and we'll start building this
we've also got a battery power source
and a monitor over here yes but let's
actually see if it works first before we
start building things dodgy old keyboard
and mouse here from goodness knows when
so we've got a noobs SD card in there
one thing you have forgotten to give me
battery power yep so be interested know
how long we could power this off a
battery to see if we could film with it
but sure so the other nice thing we've
got dual HDMI I think that sets you my
zero so that's going to there so that
hopefully should now boot see what we've
kept it's doing something that lights a
come on let's turn the monitor on who
1080p60 looking good so far
and it's booting into raspbian resizing
the file system rebooting in five
seconds so it's all working and I always
use it from the command line so I never
used to the things so hopefully that
will shut down there we ll
shutdown so let's put this together and
now sure we'll now edit this is a nice
man charged with some music
[Music]
one thing I came to do when building
these things put the screws in upside
down to start with because that way
holds things together as he sort of
acting I don't know I just think the
point of its work better is faith and
the non point of it so there we have a
thing built the other thing we do is put
the fan shim on just to keep it nice and
cool these things run fine without it
but they do start to throw them is he
going to be a video editing on it it
might get a little over warm so what we
end up in this package is fan from the
up a little control board with the fan
screws into and I like a wall pop on
this assembled so you should attach the
fan to this first to get you to build it
for me Steve I'm getting that impression
several hours later we got the thing in
and now this just clips over the GPIO
pin so you can still use them like that
and now it'll now blow nice cold air
onto the system for us but you've got me
another toy as well haven't you sure but
you've got another story which is a cog
some form that I think it's the camera
module now the one thing I found with
these cameras is that they do not like
being touched just need to be some sort
of focus control so we'll pull there now
this is now right in the way so we'll
take that off so you just pop that in
there that looks like in place we've now
got the camera attached and pop this
famishing back on making sure to get it
accurately line over the pins
quite a clever design we going to shoot
it on this camera as well let's see what
we can achieve all right so that colored
screen that's the post is it yeah yeah
the bootloader displays out in the GPU
and then it loads the kernel off the SD
card and eventually the kernel starts up
and we're into noobs so I think I need
to configure the camera first
so the fans really he's blowing air down
nice and quiet
that's good yep we could find out how
cold the CPU is measure ten thirty nine
point zero degrees so we're going to
turn on the interfacing options we want
the camera enabled yes camera enabled
excellent
would you like to reboot now yes so if
we do brass be feared
- err there we are yeah of course the
cameras upside down low so you're going
through looking at the options and just
yeah pending them to a command line - to
mp4 so there we have it there Sean so
it's working you just need to work out a
record with it
stopping us loading a different programs
coding data again from storage into
memory as well and then we can start
that program instead kind of invertible
and that's some a statistically weaker
but if you didn't do that right so
there's a little bit of all's you should
be careful about when you're designing
these kind of things